resistance fighters say they are still
battling a taliban assault on the
pangaea valley the last independent
afghan province taliban sources had
earlier claimed they had seized the
valley but opposition forces in pangea
say they have not given up
thousands of regional militia fighters
and former afghan army troops have
gathered in the mountainous region
former vice president amurula saleh
who's been leading the resistance
fighters denied taliban claims he left
the country
well meanwhile in the capital kabul
several people were reportedly killed
and many injured by celebratory gunfire
on friday night
let's hear now from some eyewitnesses
last night my sister marmie was hit by
shots fired into the air a bullet hit
her in the side of her body and she was
injured
later we took her to a private hospital
they told me that there was no treatment
there
the medical staff then took my sister to
an emergency hospital
we still don't know how she is
the people were very scared children
were injured and a number of people were
killed our request to the islamic
emirate of afghanistan is that the
people should be made aware whenever
there is a shooting everyone was firing
from their houses and it was not clear
who these people were
journalist franz marty now joins us for
more from kabul hello to you france um
so resistance fighters in the pangaea
valley say that they are fighting on
despite taliban claims of victory
what are you hearing about the situation
there
the situation is hard to verify because
telephone antennas in the punch here are
not working so um one cannot call there
furthermore both sides engage in like
heavy propaganda which is obviously
biased so the taliban have uh never
officially claimed to have taken punch
here and uh sources close to the taliban
who have done so also retracted this
today they claimed that they have like
most of punch here but like acknowledge
not all of it so that finding is going
on is certainly true which side has the
upper hand is almost impossible to say
well france a top u.s general has warned
of civil war if the taliban failed to
consolidate their power
do you see this as a real possibility
first of all there has been practically
a civil war going on not only during the
past 20 but during the past 40 years in
afghanistan so
this wouldn't be as such new that said
at the moment
except for a punch here which is like a
small resistance pocket there is no sign
that there could be like major
resistance and like a multi-factional
civil war uh erupting in afghanistan of
course a lot will depend of what the
taliban do for example if they don't get
the economy under control and uh people
begin to become desperate it is possible
that it comes to armed uprising um but
given that the taliban are quite much in
control
it is hard to see how this
would like immediately lead to to a
multi-factional civil war
well we're also hearing that the taliban
want to establish diplomatic relations
with germany and also receive financial
aid from berlin
can you tell us more
official statements in this regard don't
exist or at least not that i know there
there are talks and vague statements
from both sides what the talks are about
in general it is no secret that the
taliban crave uh international
resistance and they also made always
clear that they want international aid
to continue to flow not only from
germany but from from any country uh so
that this is happening is clear that
these are taliban demands um to what
extent like germany engages in this uh
is really hard to tell
friends marty in kabul we appreciate
your reporting thank you